There’s no easy way to say this so I’m
just going to come right out and say it: Gentlemen,
it would appear our sperm counts are dropping…
a lot.
That’s according to a new meta analysis
of studies that have looked at sperm counts
from men in western countries going all the
way back to 1973.
The study found that the average total sperm
count has dropped by over 59%, while the average
concentration of sperm has dropped over 52
percent.
I know that might be hard to hear, and denial
is a natural response.
Even the lead researcher said it was hard
to believe.
But unfortunately it looks like the study
is pretty solid.
There have been meta analyses of sperm count
studies in the past, but critics have never
been satisfied with them.
One such meta analysis from 1992 --known as
the Carlsen study-- looked at 61 studies and
also found sperm counts were dropping.
But critics say the Carlsen study is flawed
because one of the studies it used contributed
30% of the participants, disproportionately
skewing the results.
Even with this significant flaw, the authors
of the latest meta analyses describe the Carlsen
study as a “seminal paper” on sperm count,
which is the funniest joke I’ve ever heard
a scientist make and I wish I thought of it.
Anyway, with their latest paper, these smart-alecs
sought to correct the Carlsen study’s misfires.
They drew their data from 185 studies, the
largest of which contributes only 5% of the
participants.
The study used data from almost 43,000 men
who were well distributed across nearly 40
years and 50 countries.
The studies were chosen because the men in
them were not having their sperm counted because
of infertility issues, and the analysis accounted
for tons of factors like age and how long
the men had gone since they last uh… “gave
a sample,” so to speak.
Even with this ultra-conservative approach,
the results look bad.
In 1973 the average sperm concentration was
99 million per milliliter.
As of 2011 it had dropped to 47 million per
millilitre.
That’s not too far from the point when odds
of conception start to take a hit, the 40
million mark.
And there’s more bad news: the rate of decline
doesn’t seem to be showing any signs of
slowing.
Now the question I’m sure you’re asking
is, “Why?
What’s causing such a remarkable drop off?”
That’s a question a study like this can’t
answer.
The authors speculated it may be due to increased
exposure to certain chemicals like pesticides,
lead, or fire retardants, both before birth
and as an adult.
Sperm count can be affected by stress, obesity,
and smoking too.
It’s even known to fluctuate based on season
and climate, leading one scientist unconnected
to the study to speculate that global temperature
increases could be a contributor.
As if there weren’t enough reasons to worry
about climate change, apparently it might
be cooking our huevos too.
The new study isn’t perfect of course, and
skeptics have noted that the original studies
that it drew from didn’t account for the
men’s health and lifestyles, both factors
that can impact sperm count, so there could
be some variability there.
And sperm count methodology has not been standardized
across countries.
Still, other scientists have said that for
a definitive answer on declining sperm count,
this is as close as we’re going to come.
To repeat though, this is just really strong
evidence that there is a decline, and a pretty
alarming one at that.
But the cause or causes are still very much
unknown.
For the continued propagation of the human
race, more research and sperm is needed.
Sperm isn’t just useful for baby making,
it may have medical uses too, like delivering
cancer drugs.
Check out Trace’s video here for the craziest
thing I’ve ever heard.
Alright guys, are you worried about this news
or are you confident in your frosted mini
mes?
Let us know in the comments, don’t forget
to subscribe, and I’ll semen you next time
on Seeker.